[Musique]
vous avez quelque chose à rajouter non
mais quand vous enverrai fait l'émission
ce soir si je réponds ce riz plan cul
c'est bon exact était déjà à m'asseoir
tout qu'est ce que j'en ai à demain soir
d'abord je nique devant barcelone psg
non mais
[Applaudissements]
la lampe de poche
bien que je reviens quand je suis calmé
bon ben vous reviendrez chikhaoui
d'agostin boli jusqu'à maintenant vous
vous excusez moi je m'excuse je savais
qu'il fallait pas lire on a déjà dit on
de faire je vais me sanctionne tout de
suite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est vrai en action j'ai fait recours
je vous en je vous retire votre cash et
du jour et je le donne à une association
ça fait déjà deux fois je suis d'accord
c'est vraiment une association je vous
le dis la moitié comme hôtel la moitié à
leh la moitié la moitié j'accepte la
sanction mer ce monstre de leur chef
merci et éviter le mot sanction
n'arrivait pas vu son malade
bon alors été chassé pour avoir leur ip
ah non
[Musique]
j'étais petit tout petit
on donne l'intégralité du cachet aux
restos du coeur c'est fait
voilà